hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another business tools video today I
want to talk about one of my favorite
tools to run their business and it's a
service called Dropbox so I'm going to
scroll down the dropbox you may have
heard it before but I'm going to tell
you how I use it maybe there's a couple
insights that you can use from it as
well so let me load that up so this is
Dropbox you can create an account
basically what it does is the extra
drive on your computer and it allows you
to share files with other people that
you will need to share files with so
I'll give you a couple examples of what
I do so I'll load up here so this is my
dropbox and on my dropbox i have
different categories so business
personal salsa etc and i'll show you how
i use it so the other people have to
have dropbox for use in it so on a
personal example i have a folder that i
call dad mom and Evan and my parents
have signed up for this account as well
and basically what happens is we use
this to share pictures so I have a young
son just over two years old and they'll
often take care of him and take pictures
and we'll take pictures and everybody
wants pictures of a young child to you
know add to their collection so what
we'll do is we'll put it into this
Dropbox folder whenever we've taken new
pictures and what that will do is if I
put pictures up here into this folder
it'll automatically download it to their
computer and then what they'll do is
they'll take the pictures off and it
will store it in a different folder and
it will remove it from from this folder
and so you'll see this empty because
we've already taken the pictures out
this is a great way to share pictures
you don't have to ask them to click on a
link or they don't have to wait for long
download dropbox automatically loads
when you turn on your computer and it
automatically starts downloading any new
files that have been added to your
shared folders so if anybody's add
pictures or documents it'll
automatically start putting them onto
your computer so you don't have to you
know wait and click on different links
that come in I use it for other personal
reasons so you know wedding pictures we
took pictures out of friend's wedding
and added pictures in there and so they
can go in and download those pictures
father's day songs all the all sorts of
stuff
so that's personal side on the business
side I use it a couple ways so here's
one example and I tend to capitalize the
ones that are shared folder says I know
who have sharing it with summary is my
marketing manager I have to click on any
of these files here this is a shared
folder so the one thing you have to
watch out for is if I remove something
from this folder it also removes it from
the folder in her computer so you might
want to have backups just in case or
have clear communications as to you know
when you can delete something so with
with my parents i'll send them copies of
the pictures that i already have in my
computer so they take it off that's fine
because they don't want to clog up that
that folder so with maria here are some
files that she's working on marketing
related stuff for our business and what
i can do is i can know what any of these
files so if i wanted to see you know
what this interview document is i can
double click on that loaded edit it save
it and it'll save it in this folder and
then also be updated on Maria's computer
so as soon as she turns on her computer
she'll download the file again
automatically and it'll have all my
comments in it so instead of sending
attachments back and forth it's an easy
way to edit file share files that can
help you with your business so we tend
to keep things in here and Maria doesn't
usually delete too much unless we don't
need that those files anymore so I can
easily see the files that she needs my
feedback on she just puts it in dropbox
the other way that I use it in terms of
sharing files is with sod who's my video
editor and he's somebody who I hired
through odesk which is another service
that I love using has the outsourced
tasks and what I'll do here is so i'll
create these videos and I'm not the
greatest video editor it takes me a long
time and I'm not really good at it so I
hired so had it was really good at it
and what I'll do is I'll create the
videos and I'll put them in my dropbox
and what happens is the automatically
get uploaded to his computer so he can
then download these automatically and
whenever he's done with it he puts the
finished version back into the dropbox
as well so i can see here that there are
1 2 3 4 5 different videos that he's
still
working on that I've done and he's
finished one about Pierre Omidyar who's
the founder of ebay for client tell us
that I'm working with so what I'll do
here then is I have the folder also on
my computer so this is out of dropbox
and I will drag that finish file in here
so it's ready to be uploaded and then
I'll delete the source code stuff from
his folder because we don't need that
anymore and it's a great way to be able
to manage documents so when we first
started he would send me files and I
would have to send him files and zip it
up and unzip it and just became a huge
headache but for this one it's great
because whenever i finish recording new
videos like this one i'll save it i'll
put it in here into my dropbox with him
it automatically goes to his computer
he'll work on the files he'll put it
back in here and I can just drag it over
to my local folder and an outside of
Dropbox and use it which is fantastic so
perfect to share files with outsource
workers as well now a couple other ways
that I use it if I go back to my dropbox
you can also have a public folder and
this is information that you want to
share with the world if you want so
online the vidual folders if it's my
parents or Maria or sad those folders
can only be shared with those people so
I invited both my parents to join me on
my that folder with my parents and only
we can access it if I want to then share
information with the public you can put
it in your public folder you can see
it's got a special a little globe icon
in there and you can put whatever you
want in that folder but it's going to be
accessible to everybody so if there's
files that you want everybody to have
access to you know maybe you don't know
how to upload it to your website or its
too time-consuming you can just put in
your public folder and then send them a
link to those files to anybody who
you're working with we may not have
dropbox and in the last way that i use
it is i use it as my own personal
storage so most of the folders that
you'll see if i click on my business
they're not shared with anybody it's
just my personal online storage so
instead of using a backup program
Dropbox is my backup so I put all my new
files in draw
box so I can access them from any device
so if I have my iPad I can get all my my
Dropbox files and if I have a computer
right office and the computer at home I
can just sync them up so if I go to the
office work on some file save it by the
time I get home and load up my computer
it'll download all the changes that I've
made I can also access it remotely so if
I go on vacation I can just log in any
computer and find all the files and if
you do then decide to upgrade your
computer all you have to do is install
dropbox and it'll automatically get all
of those files for you instead of having
to move to a zip drive or whatever and
then get it over to your new computer so
I find it super helpful to backup my
files as well so those are the three
main ways that I use it so the share
with other people friends family and
business to have a public folder that I
can share with the general public if I
want to and then as a backup system for
all of my files so I hope you guys find
that useful if anybody is using Dropbox
maybe there's a couple of new ways you
can use it if you haven't used dropbox
go check it out i'm sure you get a lot
of benefit from it I've mentioned some
of it here it's free for up to two
gigabytes so my parents are on that free
plan maria's on that free plan since I
used it a lot more share with a lot of
people and I use it as my backup system
I'm on the 50 gigabyte plan for 999 a
month so still pretty cheap and super
helpful as I use it to run a business so
hopefully that helped you guys if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up I'd also love to hear your thoughts
and feedback if you want to leave a
comment below this video and stay tuned
for the next episode
you
you